WESLEY CHUN: Greetings,
developers, and welcome
to "The G Suite Dev Show."
In this episode, we conclude our
two-part series on field masks.
I'm your host Wesley Chun.
In the last video, we discussed
reading data from an API
and how you can use
field masks to control
the amount of data that
gets returned-- you know,
partial response?
Well, today we'll
focus on rights,
or more likely updates--
you know, via post,
put, or patch?
Well, you already
know that field masks
aren't things you wear but
instead work like a filter.
More specifically for updates,
think of them as a bit mask,
where data represented
by bits that are on
will be updated, whereas
those that are off are ignored
and remain the same.
You pass in a field you're
updating along with its name
in the mask.
Generally, the field
mask will consist
of exactly the attributes
you're updating.
If you provide additional
fields in the mask that
are not in the request, those
attributes will be reset.
Yes, I'll show you
what I mean in a bit.
Right now let's look at our
first example, this Google
sheet.
Let's say we want to
bold the first row.
You'd send this JSON to the API.
Ignoring fields
for a moment, you
can clearly see
that the repeat cell
request affects the first row.
In particular, we want to
set the cells user entered
format slash text format
slash bold attribute to true.
The payload looks legit without
fields, so why is it there?
Well, remember how I
said that the field
mask will consist of exactly
the fields you're updating?
Well, here we only
want to affect
each cell's bold attribute but
no other text format field.
Well, for fun, let's
add the italic flag.
Now our request affects
bold and italics.
Since we don't have a italics in
the request, bold will be set,
but italics will be reset.
Make sense?
All right, here's a
more extreme example.
Let's just remove the
last part of that mask.
Well, now it's a super-set
making up all text format
fields.
Any field not in the
request will be reset.
In this case, while
bold will still be set,
all others will be reset.
Yep, you can kiss
italics goodbye again.
But now the same goes for
strike-through and underline.
The original font family
and size will come back too.
Well, if you want to
specify all fields,
you can use asterisk as
a shorthand alternative
to listing every
single one, which
you'd have to look up anyway.
But be wary that
if the API changes,
you could have
inadvertent side effects.
So minimize your
use of the asterisk.
Here's the original JSON
in actual Python code
that bolds row number one,
leaving all other attributes
untouched.
Also see the Sheets API
page on update field masks.
Now let's bold some
text with Google Slides.
Instead of cells, it's
text on the slide.
Given you already
have the text box ID,
this JSON bolds the first eight
characters in the text box.
Notice that the field's
value is simpler here,
no user entered format
slash text format.
Well, that's because
the root object
for the slide's request is style
so you don't have to specify
any other attributes.
Whereas for Sheets,
the root object
was cell, meaning you needed
the full path from the cell down
to the bold flag, meaning
user entered format
slash text format slashed bold.
Each API differs,
so check the docs
to determine your root objects.
Here's some Python
that implements
bolding of the first eight
characters of the text box.
And that's almost the
entire story on field masks.
I'd like to share a few
parting tips as we wrap up.
One, for the Sheets
and Slides APIs,
fields for read operations
is an API call parameter,
like you see here.
But for write
operations, they're
an attribute you set
in your requests.
Updates may also have
fields as a parameter.
But this depends on the API and
possibly your client library.
Two, some recent APIs
have also started
supporting the dotted
attribute notation,
so you can use periods
instead of slashes.
This makes the APIs more
consistent with Google protocol
buffers.
But not all API
is supported yet.
So if you try it
and it doesn't work,
you're going to get
an HTTP 400 error
and need to change the
dots back to slashes.
Want to learn more about
proto buffs and field masks?
Check out this page in the docs.
Three, when we discussed
field masks with read,
it's all about what comes
back in the response and not
the actual API request.
In other words, you can have
non-read actions that send back
data that you can filter.
In this example, creating
a new presentation
with the Slides API isn't a
read operation but acts like one
due to its response payload.
The API creates a document
and then returns a payload
as if you called get on it,
which then you can filter.
The field masks we're
using requests just
a presentation ID plus
the IDs of all the slide
pages and objects on each page.
We pass in those
fields in the same way
for this massive
write-plus-read operation.
And four, to
complete our journey,
we'll look at another
read-plus-write example
that uses both read
and write field masks.
The example updates
a Google sheet,
but it has this include
spreadsheet in response flag
you see here.
That requests the
updated Sheet data
be added to the
response payload, which
then can be filtered, limiting
the amount of data returned.
The data has a header row
and a first column made up
of time stamps, where the
update request changes the time
stamps, adjusts the date
in year, month, day format.
In the code, we
request the API return
just a Sheet's name and
the URL plus the names
of all the individual Sheets.
Well, how's that for the
kitchen sink example?
Field masks in the
update request body
and field masks in the call
to obtain a partial response--
well, that wraps up our
journey into field masks.
Be sure to tune into
part 1 if you missed
our show on partial response.
The field masks guide
in the Slides API docs
is the most comprehensive,
covering read and write.
So check it out if
you haven't already.
And check out the last link
to see more episodes of "The G
Suite Dev Show."
Now that you know how to
use field masks in read
and write API calls,
it's time for you
to try out field masks to
build that awesome app.
Be sure to subscribe
to our channel
to get the latest from
Google Developers.
This is Wesley Chun, and we'll
see you the next time on "The G
Suite Dev Show."